và báo chí phải báo sát từ tiêm, tôim trọng sự thật.
Lý kỳ lý của nhé dân thăm cái đêm, sất phản.
Đi như thế này, nó là tình báo chí một tôi tổn tảing sống được có chịn đợt là phải là báo được tương
tăng này tốt.
Sức mạnh của báo chí trước khiến nó mở sự thật.
Sự thật ấy phải được kịp chứng, là trong lối cảnh đầy đồ.
Công bị làm miao mỏ, bất kể những gặp lực.
Kịp thầy, tất hiện những vướng mặt trong tự thuy chính xanh.
Bản hình như mô hình hay, cách làm tốt.
Lên tiếng vào vệ tính người ngay thang, giám nghĩ giám làm người lý chục.
Báo tắc phẩm báo chí tốt, thông hiết thiệt.
Vậy giống những lời là gặp tỏ bố lực.
Điều quân sọng là bài báo gáo, phần hình đúng sự thật có ý của chất nhẹ.
Chạm đến bố nè sạ hội.
Tăng cần được ra phy.
Báo chí, cần thấp ra, mình tình thần xây dất.
Cái nghĩ đúng hơn, phê bình có tâm,
cộng hú và có cơ sở,
đúng tranh và thật trọng khách quan không quy chủ,
không làm hạn mọng những người đang lúc lực lời người.
Trong phòng chống, thông hiểu nglão phi đều cửa,
báo chí tiếp tục là tình giám sát quan trọng của sao?
Các nhà máo, cần xuống khảm, nhưng cũng phải tình thảo, kiếm quyết.
Nhưng phải nhé thoàn, sắc bán, nhưng phải tương thủ pháp lợt vào đất đề gẹp.
Đúng tranh và cái sai, đúng hợt báo vệ khi đúng,
tạm thì không khi quyết khích cảm bộ giám làm đám chí tiếp trẻ.